honest is there anybody here who loves
joe biden we have any taliban in here is
there anybody
[Applause]
you're a taliban
go home bro you're free
you got your country back
you're not really taliban you're just
afghani
you're from pakistan that's not even the
same [ __ ] you racist [ __ ]
and who's this black dude co-signing
everything you're doing
[Applause]
wait a minute are you black are you
where he's from
you're from somalia hey
you changed up once you got over here
that's a fact
you got them braces you are not the
captain now you [ __ ]
well the
motherboard was captain crunch did you
see the teeth in that fucker's face
before the quarantine women had the
metoo movement doing amazing work
quarantine hits
silence
it's almost like you enjoyed being in
the house cooking and cleaning all day
[Applause]
all we need to do is give you a banana
bread recipe and all your [ __ ]
problems went away
[Laughter]
you know you can't get me tuned in the
kitchen lady
i just want to let you all know right
now ladies uh i am with you i think is
your body your choice i agree with you
on that
i agree with you when you say that men
should have no say in the decisions you
make with your bodies those are your
decisions to make and yours alone and i
feel that way because uh at the end of
the day when we all go up to heaven and
god's like why are we all killing babies
we're gonna be like y'all
i think they're very clear whose
decision this was god
looks like you need to pay for your sins
babe
even though i paid for your sins
i don't know if you're chinese by the
way miss i just you're not chinese
taiwanese so
chinese very soon
right
[Applause]
there's a couple chinese people in here
like he gets it he gets it
i'm rooting for you
you're like asian ukraine
like
is this your girlfriend sir
you're on a date
oh you don't know if you are not oh my
god bro
he goes we're on a date and she goes are
we
[Music]
oh no sir you don't realize you're in
squid games right now dude like
this guy is so adorable he's the whitest
white guy you've ever sir stand up so
everybody can see what's going on like
okay sit down
you look like a senator's gay son
[Applause]
how long have you known him
a few years
so for a few years you've known him
well because you for a few years you've
known him and then today he thinks it's
the first date and you think you're just
hanging out
don't don't do that don't do that
she said all our friends are here that
doesn't mean [ __ ]
this guy put on his best hoodie
like he was meticulous with this outfit
like he's like is the blazer too much
okay let me put on my periwinkle blue
hoodie underneath
just dress it down a little bit but let
her know i have money dude like i
i got a couple bucks you know
i believe in this guy right here this is
a nice [ __ ]
alberta trump fan like this is
this is what i'm talking about this
switch it he's going like this but he's
looking at me he's like yeah baby
where the [ __ ] you think you're going
dude
what is that cat are you wearing
camouflage
dude we can see you're gay bro it
doesn't
it's not hiding anything bro
the [ __ ] is wrong with this guy
is your background with eyebrows like
that
you're from the axis of evil iran
i got it right
i took a risk with that one guys
because if i was wrong that was racist
but i'm right
now are you are you muslim jewish
you're eight i didn't not what you
believe [ __ ] like
what what does your dick look like
are you snipped
you're snipped okay jewish well actually
muslims do it too
what are your parents
your dad is is he muslim
well your mom has not snipped hopefully
it is the middle east though dude you
never know
they'd be nip tucking that coochie down
there boy
bro you said that [ __ ] so
matter-of-factly they're like well my
father has snipped
my mother i don't remember uh
i saw it once on the way out and nothing
hit me on the head so maybe they did cut
it off
you got you gotcha they're really about
this that you guys don't believe like
i'm trying to get you to heaven bro
[Music]
welcome back doc
we needed you don't touch me right now
dude
[Music]
this guy just took a piss
literally just goes to the bathroom
hands dry as [ __ ]
and then comes to give me a pound dude
and i know you grab your [ __ ] dick
like a chimpanzee bro you just [ __ ]
just
just knuckle it out like walt jr just
[Applause]
are you albino
oh [ __ ]
are you sure you're albino bro
are you white or black
you're black oh [ __ ] bro
this is the list say the n-word and
prove it prove it what do you say say
the n-word and prove it
hilarious because this mexican right
next to you said the n-word a thousand
times in his life
come on bro say that [ __ ] you got it
that's funny so do you feel
uncomfortable saying the n-word because
people don't notice that you're black
jesus christ bro
that got heavy dude that one was heavy
right
i know you're black but you seem very
caucasian when you sit down
bro the way he hit that r right there
dude how you doing buddy
good good got the toes out and
everything bro
brought the toes out on a saturday night
bro
and nails i didn't see the net oh you
are fabulous out here to say look
i think this is the first game many
people here saw
they're just getting used to bosnians
bro let them [ __ ]
we got some we got some bosnians in here
thank you for socializing with other
people for once
y'all stick together huh
and nobody knows anything about y'all
they just know you're here
and that you're muslim and white and
we're like that's possible
white muslims what the [ __ ] is going on
[ __ ] is confusing when you first find it
now are you guys muslim or you
because it's split right isn't bosnia
like half
it's majority it's like it's like
majority muslim and then the other is
normal and then uh
it's like 51 muslim and then 49 going to
heaven and then like
[Applause]
i'm just kidding don't jump me after the
show you crazy [ __ ]
these [ __ ] been trying to kill
liam neeson for a decade bro just
leave liam neeson alone bosnians
scary ass white people leave him alone
leave his family alone
why you gotta steal his [ __ ] family
by the way guys
that's hello right oh what is it
it's mostly ciao
that's italian homie
you see this [ __ ] just try to
steal
italian bro
what's thank you gracias [ __ ]
like
they just making up their language
thinking we're not gonna catch on on
that [ __ ] bro
we're not that stupid out here in
america
i thought hello is travel
that's more formal but it does mean
hello
so you just wasted my [ __ ] time
what is your name bro what is your name
amel what we got we got amel
armin
ben
[Applause]
this [ __ ] moved to america he's
like i am none of that bosnian [ __ ] no
more
give me the whitest name
let me fit in with these people
ben just regular ben and what it is what
about you tariq you're a white tariq
black people you can't allow this on
juneteenth
it's juneteenth
you're gonna let this white boy take a
black neck to reek bruh
what's your name black guy sitting next
to him if you say something super white
casper
y'all traded names at the door
uh what's your name black guy
say what
kevin no
oh
[Music]
i love when i meet muslims and i say
mubarak
white people love things about us white
people
wow
wow this is so crazy
here take extra banana thank you for
banana okay
it's dude oh it's your christmas but
don't y'all believe in jesus we do so
then
christmas is christmas
what does it mean iaid mubarak
is that your daughter
[Applause]
mubarak
are you here with your wife bro
[Applause]
you're not married as your girlfriend oh
but you were married before
god you got you and do you think you'll
get married to her
[Applause]
i'm sorry sweetheart
i'm sorry you found out today
[Music]
yeah they already know but they don't
every girl goes into the relationship
thinking oh yeah you don't want to get
married he's not serious but then they
grind you away
oh the woman of
course do we get out of it
yeah it's 100 for the woman like think
about it you get married to us you get
half our [ __ ]
right
we get married to you we get half your
[ __ ] here's the difference
no girl is dumb enough to marry a dude
that got less [ __ ] than her
[Applause]
only we're stupid enough to marry these
broke [ __ ] bro
that's how great [ __ ] feels you're
inside's a [ __ ] like [ __ ] he's half my
[ __ ] really
what am i gonna do with all this [ __ ] i
got all this [ __ ] i'm gonna keep it to
myself this is crazy
this guy went through it once he's like
i'm not getting burned again
guaranteed by next year they're married
guaranteed
guaranteed
100 guarantee
i promise you but this is how it starts
it's how it starts stop
we do the same thing with anal it's the
same [ __ ] right slowly
you slowly grind away and wear them down
right
right we marry them then finally we get
in the ass gotcha [ __ ]
you know i gotcha there's no prenup for
anala
what if he what if he changed his mind
sweetheart what if he was like i would
really love to get married
you never wanted to get married
really
your mom was married three times
nah that's some fire [ __ ] right there
i'm not gonna lie
she probably crazy like your mom's
probably out of her mind crazy but she
got fire [ __ ] if she got three
different dudes
three different dudes to get down on one
knee
before you marry her you gotta try out
some of that mom [ __ ] bro
[Applause]
i guess the apple doesn't fall far from
the tree